hola soy lujo molas y soy de té de
personajes en pixar hola yo soy jamie
spears y también soy dt de los
personajes en pixar empezamos en pixar
con world y como pasantes y nuestra
tarea fue hacer una multitud enorme de
robots de fondo la elección de hoy
tratará sobre cómo crear una gran
multitud de robots usando solamente
algunas partes simples
quise llevar a wally de un mundo en el
que ya no había robots a otro donde hay
toneladas de robots me gusta ese
contraste y repentinamente hacerlo
sentir como si estuviera solo en una
multitud tratamos de crear un mundo en
el que los robots hicieran todas las
tareas que quisieras lo que hicimos
primero fue observar cruceros e hicimos
una lista de cada uno de los empleos ahí
después trabajamos sobre eso y tratamos
de pensar en la equivalencia robótica de
esos empleos rápidamente vimos que había
más robots de los que podría construir
en mi vida entonces como pasantes yaacov
y yo teníamos la tarea de hacer este
gran reparto de robots pero no queríamos
diseñar cada uno específicamente cierto
afortunadamente estaba el animador ambos
y él tuvo una gran idea sobre cómo
abordar ese proceso soy un gran fan del
ego y quería que los personajes de fondo
fueran lo mejor posible se me ocurrió
que si diseñamos un sistema modular nos
permitiría agregar y quitar diferentes
partes del personaje para los personajes
de fondo así podríamos hacer todo lo
necesario y todo sería del mismo mundo
al hacerlo así podríamos construir 10
cabezas 10 brazos y 10 cuerpos y aunque
solo hayamos construido 30 piezas
podríamos hacer miles de combinaciones
diferentes sí y de hecho hay una rama de
las matemáticas sobre todo eso cálculo y
combinaciones que se conoce como
combinatoria
la combinatoria de lo que se trata la
lección de hoy empezaremos con algunas
piezas pequeñas y construiremos un gran
reparto de robots